the Joe Rogan experience and get stories
about you know like I have a bunch of
Asian friends and they're getting
bullied like it's it's so terrible like
there was a story in Texas a dude
stabbed a guy and his two kids - in six
what yes it happened a couple months I'm
two two-year-old two-year-old six year
old in the in the guy because he thought
they were Chinese why in Texas at a
sample sale club what
yes it's people are going nuts over this
thing you know like we all end this
together but you don't need to take it
just because even if he was Chinese like
he's an American probably you know he
didn't bring it over here even if he was
Chinese from China yeah it's not the
person who made the [ __ ] disease
that's that's like me who your oldest
yeah two-year-old six Yost I just feel
like this whole time right now is giving
people and it's a very small group of
people yeah you know and that's why I
hate when certain people go white people
like no no no no it's a very small
number of white people doing it I hate
when people generalize a group like even
the whole Michigan thing so open carry
state they showed up at this lady's
office you know the governor's the
governor's office they were carrying the
rifles they were protesting which they
had every right to and people go out
here people or you see it a social media
well these white people that no no no no
there's three hundred fifty six million
people in the United States that many
know isn't it I believe so Jesus Christ
believe so there's only seven hundred
people there yeah you know and probably
a third of them just wanted to protest
to get their jobs back just to go back
to work yeah so you can't generalize
people and you can't hate on people
because where they're from
well you can't hate on people that are
so [ __ ] dumb they bring guns to the
governor's house
like what that is ridiculous like what
do you do I agree are you trying to take
over the governor like what are you
doing like why are you bringing guns are
you expecting a war are you going
hunting like what are you doing what are
you bringing [ __ ] guns
that's that's some weird [ __ ] when
people do that when
they they protest with like [ __ ]
coalition of coughs and [ __ ] like what
are you doing look why do you have a
rifle there was a guy it was a clip I
saw a guy was like a white guy to a
white guy it was like hey I want my job
back too but why the gun and the guy was
like it just walked away it doesn't mean
if you're protesting that's the thing
about the Second Amendment and I'm a pro
Second Amendment man I believe in it I
think it's important but there's a lot
of dumb [ __ ] out there there's
a lot of dumb dumb [ __ ] out
there and they get to have guns too I
mean I support that in a lot of ways I
have to support that if I support the
Second Amendment but it was a certain
point in time you got to go why the [ __ ]
are you bringing a gun to Sam's Club why
why do you have a [ __ ] a.k around
your waist when you're walking through
the aisles looking for toilet paper like
what are you doing it's it's it's
amazing how but but let's be honest
they're giving a pass you got a you got
a us a pass right now to act like that
because it well no I mean you do because
it's well because the president's like
those are fine people you know yeah he
said that the other day he goes those
are good people that were protesting
with the guns with the guns
those are good people it's just it's a
stupid thing to protest with guns like
what one of the nice things about this
country is that we can protest
absolutely that's a nice thing it's
beautiful it's important this is one of
the things that's been infringed upon by
this whole lockdown thing where people
you know they're being told they're then
they're not allowed to assemble it's a
gigantic part of who we are the ability
to assemble the ability to protest but I
don't think that's just what they're
doing when you're showing up with guns
you're letting them know that you're
ready to take over you're ready to do
something you might shoot somebody you
know you might if you're threatened you
might use these guns it's like okay if
if we're in that what you're escalating
way past where we're at you know if you
if you're in a situation where someone
saying hey your family have starved
hey you have to stay home hey I don't
give a [ __ ] about you okay then I
understand why you want to show that you
have guns and you get to get a bunch of
people together yeah hey we need to stay
alive here and we are our rights being
infringed upon but that's not what's
wrong but if you go back to the back
story you find out like I I don't know
all the facts but I know these people
that showed up to this rally they didn't
put on that rally it was by another
organization through through Facebook or
through some social media outlet that
put it together and they told you
Pindell to bring their guns and no they
just told people to pro chatter up to
show up so see where they're there we're
all ponds and there's at some point to
this political game
[Applause]